using SQLite makes it easy to delete
update and insert rows using highly
expressive queries one can even add new
columns as you revision your database
while retaining existing user data it's
not a surprise that just about every
popular app make some use of SQLite in
Android it's a very powerful and
important component of the Android
solution Android also provides a huge
set of helper functions to make working
with databases easy including functions
to automate query building display list
views and even utilize pre-compiled
statements for more information about
databases in android see the instructor
notes well that's what you need to know
to get started with data storage on
android all of this is documented if you
search for data storage on
developer.android.com we'll be working
with these storage api's to build our
sunshine database